we here at new rock stars are obviously
obsessed with black mirror and like many
of you are paranoid watchful eyes led us
to spot a number of Easter eggs
referencing past episodes in season four
now you think about it these Easter eggs
actually some of them have some super
interesting implications for the
extended universe of the black mirror
world so let's break them all down and
I'm gonna just list through these and
fly through them but go boy okay let's
start with the Easter eggs that we
spotted in USS Callister many of you
spotted the boys cameo by Aaron Paul
Jesse Plemons no star no so cool he was
the voice in the final scene the
anonymous gamer who talks to the
crew his face right here
there was an even sneakier cameo from
Kirsten Dunst that's Plymouth his
real-life fiancee he passed her she
passed by him in the office in the
background Wow crazy yeah I didn't I
didn't catch it all the first time
Kirsten - Nika Nika the receptionist
uses the same dating app that the guy
used in playtests in season 3 that's the
haunted house episode remember he hooked
up with a girl in the on the big nap the
DNA scanner device from Jessica lemons
character was made by TCK our systems
it's the same company that made the
afterlife software in the San Junipero
episode last season they show up a
couple times
yes and then two of the planets from USS
Callister ranek be in scalene for stress
signal from the surface of scallion for
those are the names of the killers in
white bears oh and then Daly drinks from
a brand of milk called Ryman Raymond
which is a nod to Raymond it men against
fire last season the soldier episode she
mentioned actually that her family owned
a farm which is kind of fun ok moving on
quickly to Archangel episode 2 when the
mom is considering the program at the
beginning the demo shows the troubling
imagery of a soldier firing a gun which
is from and against fire that's actual
footage I definitely caught that one
teenage Sara's bedroom there's a poster
for hurt us that was the name of the
rapper and hated that nation who was one
of the targets at some point as well as
a poster for her liqu shadow that's the
game the scary game from Ellie test so I
guess that game exists in this world now
I want to move on quickly to Crockett
had some of the most interesting Easter
eggs and I have a big question for ya
yeah there's some crazy stuff that
happens here okay well first just to get
out of the way there's this episode
reuses mo Thomas's anyone who knows what
love is will understand you know you can
blame me yes so great that was also in
15 million merits and white Christmas
and men against fire it's kind of like
they use it every season some crazy
stuff here when Mia flips through the
hotel movie category it's kind of like
their version of Netflix the classics
option shows a robotic beyond a flower
it's the actual thumbnail from hated in
the nation so she's like able to watch
that story in her which is fun but then
within the the porn options if she's
flipping through one it's called best of
wrath babe hey babe that was the porn
that the girl ended up doing in 15
million merits and the hotel clerk at
that hotel references a tabloid story
about the host of hot shot which was the
the name of the American Idol America's
Got Talent Britain's captive show
reality contest show from that episode
so all right let's pause here just
overthink this because the implication
is that the world of 15 million merits
the one with the stationary bike
peddlers underground
Dania is the same world of the surface
world of crocodile so yeah I think it's
safe to assume but Mia's world is
powered by those poor people down below
maybe even that smokestack that she
shoved the body Burke's boyfriend down
was like exhaust from that underground
power plant which is what I was thinking
that I don't know necessarily exactly
it's that power plant but that there is
a place where this thing is real right
and it's providing energy but what
throws it off for me is when you see the
graphic novel or the comic of 15 million
merits that he's reading in the lighter
episode and it's like so that's all that
also would just be a story unless they
did the meanest thing in the world with
like hey you know we have slaves on
there let's make him into a comic those
stories into comic books so are you
saying that the world in 50 million
merits is like bigger than just that one
little place because when he goes up to
okay good yeah this is like when he goes
up to the top floor he sees a lush
forest right or is that
projection simulations I meet him he's
like who was watching their show right
they had an audience at home so there
must be like normal people out there
right is that I don't know when that
makes it even bleaker you know they get
out but let us know and so then we sent
downstairs to cycle whose cycle right in
the nation was just a story within that
world that like that's the media they
watch is this world where B's could be
used as fillers assassins anyway
it's crazy to think okay but getting
back to some of these Easter eggs in
crocodile Mia Birds an article from UK
in online that's a news agency from the
very first episode national anthem the
pizza truck that the guy gets hit by his
fences pizza that's the same place that
just lemons orders pizza from in u.s.
cows today but I guess now it's evolved
into automated delivery trucks even
though crocodiles my least favorite
episode I love that pizza was delivered
that way you guys make it a little joke
it's going out real cool and then
finally this is probably one of the
teasing missed Easter eggs if you look
at the close-up of the printout you have
to pause it one of the paragraphs that
the bottom of the article says quote of
course the real question is why anyone
would pause on what they're watching
just to read a sentence and a printed
out newspaper article says a voice in
your head before advising you to go and
share this finding on reddit just making
fun of it is exactly what happened ready
[Music]
and hang the DJ there wasn't a whole lot
of Easter eggs the dating app that we
see is the same one that I mentioned
before
I guess there's one dating app in this
universe and that's now we know how it
works in the simulated
copies of you in metal head when Maxine
goes through the drawer there's actually
a postcard from a place called San
Junipero which is pretty fun actually if
you think about it because in that
playtest episode it's like time gets
extended over and over again and all
those weird like Russian nesting dolls
of like the worlds that he's like dying
in over and over again so it's like I
can't make sense but it also looks like
Callister the the USS Callister that
also could be the name of a company
because it's written
and then on the name of the analog
screen inside the truck that the guys
trying to hack into at the beginning
that is a Callister equipment so we'll
see maybe these are just names of
everything that uh that they use ok
black Museum of course packed with every
kind yeah it truly was so just to point
out everything we spotted the gas
station it's called BRB connect like be
right back
be right back what's the name of the
first episode of season 2 with where the
guy gets all that BRB is known for yes
that couldn't see everything else it's
like rose museum there's a video screen
showing Victoria from white bear and a
newsreel that shows p.m. callo Mary's
Pig reference to the first episode we
see Mary he was good enough to marry it
as well the exhibits include Carlton
blooms hanging from that episode Carlton
bloom was the experimental artist to
orchestrate that whole thing there was
also a mannequin of the man with a gun
who chased Victoria and white there in
that weird white pattern on his ski mask
there was a copy of Harlech shadow game
from play test
there was one of the bees from hated in
the nation there's Tommy's lollipop and
Raymond's milk and the DNA scanner from
USS Callister I know that's annoying a
lot of people because didn't I rescue
the lollipop from the fridge all right
maybe I'll put it back into it she came
and she grabbed it right yeah so there's
no way that anyone should really I'll
say I'll kind of it's a river like a
recreation of it well I'll kind of buy
that the way that that character was
played a lot of these things probably
aren't legit yeah it's yes there's also
the shattered tablet screen from
Archangel we got to get close-up of that
and the bloody bathtub from crocodile
yeah and even though this is weird
because they said all the things were
like crime-related there were the
dresses worn by Yorkie and Kelly in San
Junipero like the dresses didn't seem
like any crimes were going on in that
episode but whatever so they got the
fake dresses out of the right maybe they
were based on these who knows and then
meanwhile within those flashback stories
Rollo's lab rats were named Kenny and
Hector those are the names of the
experimental lab rat characters and shut
up and dance that was a you know the web
a black male in the zone the hospital
you mentioned this before ever that roll
at work that was called st. junipers
which may have inspired Barolo to call
his virtual paradise an Junipero when he
went on to work for a TC TC KR and then
yeah you also mentioned this the graphic
novel that he reads is the story of 15
million merits now to me and lack
mirror-black museum the seen this
episode connects pretty much all the
episodes prior made me think that this
could be like one own meta dimension
where Rolo is like kind of a devil
figure he's profiting from all these all
the world's technological evils simple
simple things without it is that no no
but that's it kind of seems like that
idea of like coming to my shop and I
have already oh yeah need need full
things well it's a Stephen King story
but it's made fun of it yeah yeah I
don't know I kind of liked that idea and
some people were saying that some of the
other exhibits in the background might
have been like future episodes that we
haven't seen yet it'd be very cool are
we gonna get another season yeah no I
that mean I like the theory it's a fun
one Rollo definitely has the charisma of
like a devil character he's yeah I liked
hearing him speak he did speak a lot
throughout that entire episode would
have liked in here the female lead like
a little bit more I didn't like her a
lot I wonder if her accent couldn't hold
up over time or something but that's the
thing it's like it kind of wrecked the
twist because she's like are you
wondering why my accent changed I'm like
your accent when did I yeah like I said
nine words yes okay well those are all
the things that we were able to spot and
black mare we'd love to you know go
through and rewatch and find all the
other connections because black makers
just laid in with Easter eggs but let us
know what other because we did a
breakdown of hang the DJ and let us know
if there's any other questions you have
about this that you'd want to see us
take on in the video and let us know if
you have any shared universe theories of
exactly how the black mare universe war
beat for beat let us know thanks guys a
diagram to